denver broncos trying desperately to
have a contending team it's been a long
few years since they won the super bowl
five years ago now super bowl 50 von
miller was the mvp peyton manning walks
off into the sunset and it all goes to
crap after that frankly um you know
quarterback's been the problem and john
elway no longer the gm he fell upward to
whatever position he has now and
i mean i love john elway i got a ton of
respect for john elway he's out he's out
he'll be out after this year george
payton now takes over
should they pursue an elite quarterback
or try to build an elite defense miles
your thoughts
uh the the quick answer is yes i mean
you know
obviously you should try to build as
many elite things as you possibly can
but and i think yes obviously if deshawn
watson's available as the reporting has
been that they will pursue him they
should pursue him because that's not
somebody that just comes of becomes
available at any point in time and you
can just go out there and get but but i
think
at least with vic fangio and who knows
what's gonna happen with vic fan joe
after this season he probably is one of
those guys that should start the season
with his seat warmer on uh he's one you
you think that vic fangio should be able
to build a pretty darn good defense
because he has that reputation as being
one of the better defensive coordinators
in the league over the last however many
years so at a certain point i think you
need to expect a little bit more from
vic fangio's defense now that being said
if you get the elite qb then yeah the
elite defense is a little bit easier to
build because you're already going to be
scoring points so if you're scoring
points then that means that other teams
are going to need to pass it makes it
easier to pass rush and all those
different things that come with that so
i mean yeah you should try to get the qb
but you also need to be able i think at
this point in vic fangio's tenure to say
we are taking steps to being an elite
defense because we have this guy as our
head coach and we know that he can build
defenses like that mike
yeah and i agree with you but they need
a long-term answer at quarterback they
need something to stabilize the
franchise that's the problem and they
haven't had that in a very long time
peyton manning was a four-year stop gap
jay cutler was there for a little while
before they threw him overboard they
really haven't had since john elway a
long-term clear-cut this is our guy type
of a quarterback and uh they need that
now it's one thing to say we need it
it's another thing to say we've got it
and uh you know maybe they're a few
years away from that but for now they
consider an upgrade over drew lock who i
thought was going to be better than he's
been he's had durability issues he's had
uneven performances
do you think he'll be the starting
quarterback week one yes or no
um
yes because i don't think that the
broncos are going to get to sean watson
and i think even if they were to draft a
qb and they've got the ninth overall
pick and i think that they probably can
take one of those guys of the four
behind trevor lawrence i think it still
might behoove the broncos to start a guy
like drew locke who at least has some
experience you know he can get the ball
down the field he can manage the game at
least for you and i was one of those
guys too that i thought drew luck had
some traits i thought that he'd be
better than he has turned out to be so
far but as we sit here today at what is
it february 26th i will say i think drew
lock is going to be the starting
quarterback week one mike
i don't think he will be because you
have to factor in the new personality
and george payton who is running that
team and it's not like vic fangio is an
offensive guy so you know if if your
coach is an offensive guy then
the coach is going to make the call
on who the quarterback's going to be i
think in this circumstance the new gm
will have that that sway and i think
he's going to find someone who at least
will compete with drew locke and quite
possibly win the competition all right
let's do our one guy in one guy out
segment we've done that for every one of
these teams so far miles give me
somebody who you think the team in
denver will be adding
okay i think it will be i really wanted
to say one of those four qb's but
because
who knows what's going to happen in the
top 10 i just won't and i'll be a little
bit safer but i'll go with leonard floyd
who's an edge rusher obviously coming
off of a great year with the rams at 10
and a half sacks but he played for vic
fangio for the first few years of his
career in chicago i think especially if
the broncos decide to move on from von
miller to kind of think that they will
then you will probably see that that
slot open up for somebody who is like a
learner floyd who can come in there and
rush the passer very well now who knows
if vic fangio is going to be there
beyond 2021 but i still think that
leonard floyd can get things done for
them and would be good to pair with
somebody on the opposite side like a
bradley chub mike
all right i've got two that that i've
got in mind both on the offensive side
of the ball there was a report earlier
today or actually last night from woody
page at the denver gazette that the
broncos have actually already talked to
ryan fitzpatrick which would be
tampering but the nfl doesn't care about
tampering until it does bring in ryan
fitzpatrick let him compete with drew
locke or maybe he becomes the relief
pitcher you know i think the right way
to use ryan fitzpatrick is to know when
to put him in
and when to get him out because he can
do great things in appropriate doses the
moment he's the weaken and weak out guy
it's just a matter of time before fitz
magic flips if it's tragic but if you
are just surgical in all right let's use
him okay good now let's go back to the
other guy all right wait well uh let's
use him like brian flores did that's why
it would be perfect if he stays in miami
but now fitzpatrick thinks he should be
a starter and if he doesn't find a gig
like that maybe something like denver
would make sense another guy that i
wouldn't be surprised if he ends up in
denver alejandro villanueva because he's
got that tie to mike munshack the
offensive line coach and the steelers
aren't expected to sign villanueva
because they've got serious cap issues
all right give me a guy that you think
is going to be out
i'll say philip lindsay running back and
you know it's been interesting with him
because he was good for his first two
years but he is one of those guys at
running back that because he's an
undrafted free agent i almost think it
works against him a little bit he's a
restricted free agent right now but that
means that if the broncos give him the
original round tender
then they don't necessarily receive any
compensation back they can match the
contract but why would you want to if
you're the broncos when as you did a few
years ago you didn't even draft philip
lindsay he comes in and he rushes for a
thousand yards i think that they've
already proven as a franchise that they
can go out get a running back whoever
that happens to be they do have melvin
gordon who's facing a little bit of a
suspension there but at the same time i
just don't necessarily see why you would
need to bring philip lindsay back
because of the position he plays and
because of the production that you can
get elsewhere mike it's a shame because
he's a great kid great person great
story undrafted
from denver lived with his parents when
he first got on the team beat all odds
and just was so good they couldn't deny
him a spot on the roster but now several
years in there's somebody else who comes
along and that's the nature of the
running back position that's that's the
problem and christian mccaffrey told us
a few weeks ago
hey he just wanted to run the football
when he was a kid and i think that
attracts the better athletes you want to
be the center of attention you want to
be the guy who goes out and shows what
you can do the problem is when you get
to the nfl you look around and you say i
wish i would have done something else
because you don't get to play very long
unless you're a superstar and you're
never going to get paid even at the
highest end what you get paid is going
to pale in comparison to quarterbacks
and other players that are regarded as
more rare and more valuable all right i
think that von miller will be gone i i
don't think they're going to pick up his
option i don't think they're going to
work out a different deal i think he'd
like to to move on to a team where where
he could maybe contend for another super
bowl championship and this is one of the
reasons why i believe jj watt doesn't
have a deal yet
because even if you are comfortable with
the number that you could put together
for j.j wad and we kind of know now the
the range the tighter range of the
salary cap 180 to 183 is the maximum
range
if you sign jj watt and von miller's
available the next day and you think man
we could have used that money on vaughn
and we would rather have vaughn and
let's just see who else is out there i
just you want to know who else is out
there you want to know what doors are
open and what doors are closed before
you close the door on other people than
the guy that you're signing and i think
miller's going to be available and also
i think it's a no-brainer they're gonna
cut jeff driscoll back up quarterback
he's making like two and a half million
that money's going to get spent
elsewhere the question is will the 18
million for vaughn be spent elsewhere
but i just even though it's great he's
been there for a long time
it just feels to me like it's over
yeah and unfortunately i think that's
that's the case you just don't know how
healthy von miller's going to be coming
off that ankle injury that kept him out
for the entire 2020 season and even
though you still think that he can be a
threat i think he's probably better in a
situation where he's a pass rushing
specialist because even that last season
where he was healthy in 2019 he had only
eight sacks now only eight sacks yes is
a thing but when you look at von
miller's career he's always been a
double digit sack guy until basically
last year so i think that at that point
you probably it might be best for both
sides if von miller goes elsewhere and
look if he can be one of these guys that
becomes maybe a mercenary he goes down
to the bucks goes to kansas city i don't
know maybe the la rams take another
flyer on a guy he could be somebody that
is the difference for a championship
team
going into that 2019 season peter king
had done the math
he was halfway to bruce smith and you
know
it looked like he was going to get there
and then all of a sudden the sack
production dried up under vic fangio and
then last year zero sacks zero sacks
because zero games so he's got a long
way to go to reestablish himself but
he's still fairly young and he's highly
talented and i just think that if i'm
him it's just it's just time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports